Det finns ju verktyg idag som kan hjälpa dig att sammanfatta den och förstå den och sen kanske ringa upp forskaren och kunna ställa ganska smarta frågor.
Då kommer du ju rätt och då har du använt verktygen som död liksom men det är inte de som skrivit artiklen.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni, vad sa du, omsökt 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta, du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har renda språk.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tuerliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Helene Claesson-Geniché till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Det var det sista vi sa innan inspelningen.
Jag uttalade inte det där rätt.
Det blev jättebra.
Ja, det var det.
Men du är i alla fall chefredaktör för chefstidningen.
Ja, det stämmer.
Är det det högsta man kan nå inom ledarskap i Sverige?
Är det du som håller koll på människor som sköter sig?
Nej, det hoppas jag verkligen inte att det är det högsta man kan nå inom ledarskap i Sverige.
Nej, men vi bevakar ju forskning kring ledarskap.
Vi bevakar väl inte bevaken, men vi har koll på chefer och hur de jobbar och hur de tänker.
Men fungerar ni mest som en positiv kraft eller pratar ni någonsin om?
Belyser ni någonsin liksom toxiska chefer eller tar upp sånt?
Eller är detta mer än en tidskrift för att man ska lära sig och utbildas och få goda exempel?
Alltså vi skriver mycket om forskning om ledarskap och det bedrivs ju mycket forskning om destruktiva chefer och destruktivt ledarskap så vi skriver ganska mycket om det.
Nu alldeles nyligen skrev vi om en ny svensk studie som det finns en jättekul forskare på Försvarshögskolan som i 15-20 år har forskat om destruktiva chefer i Sverige.
Hon kommer med ny spännande forskning som visar att destruktiviteten sitter i väggarna, det sitter i kulturen, det är oerhört svårt stoppa om det väl har börjat.
Vi hade jättemycket läsning på det.
Så jag tänker att det är många som känner igen sig, inte när de tittar sig i spegeln kanske, men de känner igen sig för att de själv har haft med en chef som de har upplevt som destruktiv på ett eller annat sätt.
Jag kan tycka att det där är lite knepigt.
Vi ska komma in lite mer på vem du är och vad du gör och sånt där, men är ledarskap eller självskap, är det en science?
För ganska ofta om man tittar på de här som lyfts fram, folk tar ju alltid Steve Jobs när de pratar, chefer och ledarskap, och så säger de att det är någon sorts förebild.
Om man har läst lite biografier och sånt om honom, så verkar inte han stört skön som människa.
Han verkar ju lite små och dryg på rätt många olika sätt.
Och ändå så har ju han uppenbart lyckats göra massa grejer.
Ska man alltid sträva efter att vara en god chef för att få fram effektivitet hos människor?
Man kanske behöver vara lite toxisk ibland.
Alltså jag tror inte man behöver vara toxisk.
Det tror jag verkligen inte, men det är klart man behöver vara tydlig och man behöver vara en gång driva på, man behöver fatta jobbiga beslut.
Men att vara toxisk det är ju att göra människor illa.
Och jag tänker att det har man liksom ingen glädje av som ledare att vara en sådan person.
Jag har väldigt svårt att se att det betalar sig.
Jag köper det, samtidigt så är det bra.
Jag fattar precis vad du menar, för det blir ju så här, ska man se ledarskap som att vara en person som kan få med sig människor, få människor att må bra och få människor att prestera.
Man kan ju också se, när du säger Steve Jobs, då tänker man en person som har byggt världens största företag, känner att de har mycket pengar, disrappat hela, du vet.
Och den grejen, det är klart att man kan lyckas med den även om man är toxisk.
Men organisationer håller nog inte i längden, om de leds med toxiska principer.
Det har jag svårt att tro.
Vi kan komma tillbaks till det senare kanske.
Men jag tycker att det är intressant lite vart man drar i gränsen där.
Men vi börjar med, vem är du?
Jag är journalist i borten.
Jag har jobbat med journalistik i hela mitt yrkesliv.
Jag har varit reporter, nyhetschef, redaktör och chefredaktör.
Och idag är jag då chefredaktör på Chästing.
Om man har levt ett liv som journalist eller reporter, blir man en speciell människotyp då?
Nej jag tror inte.
Jag tror inte att vi är de samma.
Nej jag tror inte man blir en speciell människotyp.
Men jag tänker att man är en ganska nyfiken typ.
Eftersom det ändå går ut på det att prata med människor hela tiden.
Fråga människor saker.
Ta reda på saker.
Blir man inte lite cynisk per automatik för att folk ofta förställer sanningen en aning?
Jag tänker att mitt uppdrag är ju att försöka ta in flera olika perspektiv och prata med många och därmed få en bild som är så nära sanningen det går.
Det är klart att man har stött på människor som ljuger medvetet men framförallt så pratar man ju med människor som kommer från olika håll, som kommer in med olika perspektiv.
Så nej jag känner inte att jag har blivit cynisk.
Det är trevligt att någon lever kvar i det goda.
Nu kanske du inte intervjuar folk så mycket längre eller sitter på den sidan?
Jo jag gör det ganska mycket.
Har du tekniker för att få folk att slappna av sådär?
Jag har själv märkt att jag blir ofta lite mer bonnig eller sådär i mitt sätt när jag ska intervjua folk.
Då märker jag att de slappnar av och så tar de inte det så mycket på allvar och då smakpratar de mycket mer personligt.
Så jag gör ofta mycket mer fel när jag ska intervjua någon för då blir det som att de, gör du sådana grejer?
Ja men det är klart att man vill att en annan människa ska känna sig bekväm så att det är lätt att föra ett samtal liksom.
Sen är det väl skillnad om man gör ansvarsutkrävande intervjuer efter en stor skandal eller om man pratar med psykologer, forskare, chefer om hur det är att jobba som chef i Sverige.
Det blir liksom en annan grej.
Men känner du att du kommer in på livet på folk?
Jag tänker ofta när man läser sådana här chefs, vad kallar man det, men liksom uppslag i tidningar som man hittar på spa och konferensanläggningar.
Jag tänker att det är där vi hittar de här chefstidningarna.
Då står de fotade du vet mot ett miljardbord eller någonting och säger det är 16 sidor om hur de har transformerat sin organisation.
Vad är det för märkliga tidningar du läser Joel?
Det var länge sedan jag berättade dig detta kanske men är du trött på att alla är så tillrättalagda hela tiden?
Det är ju väldigt slätstrukigt i alla de här intervjuerna kan jag tycka.
Ja, alltså det blir ju inte roligt om man inte får fram personen.
Vi behöver jobba med reporterer som kan få fram människan bakom lite.
Det är ju en bransch präglad av floskler och det är ju bara att titta på LinkedIn så ser man.
Men jag tycker ändå att det är man trygg i sig själv så tycker jag att det är allt vanligare att man bjuder på ganska mycket.
Du är väl en som bjuder ganska mycket på dig själv i sociala kanaler och så.
Folk säger det men jag tycker ju privat att jag...
Jag tycker inte att jag bjuder på någonting egentligen, utan det är ju bara någons uppfattning.
Det som är privat på riktigt det håller jag ju för mig själv på något sätt.
Och så kanske det blir med alla liksom, men det är klart att vi hela tiden strävar efter att komma förbi flosklerna.
Det blir inte så rolig läsning då.
Då kanske vi blir lutade mot miljardbord, det låter inte så kul.
Jag tänkte, det var nån intervju här för ett tag sen, nu kommer jag inte ihåg vem det var med, men hette han Ola någonting?
Han sa att man inte kunde vara med barnen när man blev chef eller någonting.
Hette han Ola?
Jag vet vad du menar, det var i Dagens Industri tror jag.
Jag bara tänker att när det väl blir en sådan intervju, när någon säger någonting då som hamnar utanför, det är ju inte accepterat då.
Då blir ju det ett ultramediautbåd.
Jag tror jag läste ingenting annat.
Jag kan ju ingenting om den här människan, men även jag såg ju 48 poster om den här människan.
Vi har ju mycket sådant i e-handelsvärlden där folk har, de kanske har misskött sig lite grann och helt plötsligt blir det ett medieutbåd utan desslike för att det blir det man har nyheter om.
Det är ganska svårt att våga vara öppen också.
För att 90 procent av det man gör kanske är gott och 10 procent av det man gör är korkat.
Så är det ju på något sätt.
Så är det ju liksom.
Det är ju ett hårt klimat därute där man letar fel.
Det är ju en aktuell fråga såhär, hur kombinerar man familj och karriär.
Dels var det ju att det är ganska uddat när hon är så rak som han var där och sa det går inte att vara vd och ägna tidigt sina barn samtidigt.
Samtidigt tror jag att det också fick spridning för att det är väldigt nära många dåligt samvete av att man inte hinner med riktigt så mycket som man önskar hemma.
Eller åt andra håll ett dåligt samvete för att man inte gör sitt jobb.
Riktigt så som man önskar att man skulle göra det.
Vill du berätta lite grann om chefstidningen här och ni har även ett bolag bakom chefstidningen.
Kan du berätta lite om uppsättningen här?
Det här är det, att chefstidningen ägs av Akademikerförbundet SSR.
Och de ger chefstidningen till alla sina chefsmedlemmar och till sina HR-medlemmar.
Men sen finns det också massa andra organisationer som köper gruppprenumerationer och ger till sina chefer.
Och det finns företag som köper gruppprenumerationer och ger till sina chefer.
Och sen kan man ju också som privatperson ta en prenumeration.
Men tidningen görs, vi som gör tidningen, vi sitter på ett produktionsbolag som heter A4.
Som är ett produktionsbolag som jobbar med kunder som använder journalistik i sin kommunikation.
Så hos oss sitter en massa redaktörer, reporter, formgivare, fotografer, poddare, allt möjligt.
Som hjälper kunder då att göra journalistiska produkter.
Så man kommer till er om man vill göra en artikel som ska publiceras i en annan tidning eller?
Eller snarare så här, du är en stor organisation som Akademik i förbundet till exempel.
Och din core business är inte att göra journalistik, det är inte det du ska hålla på med, utan du lägger ut det på en byrå.
Och vi har jättemånga kunder som är från civilsamhället, det är fackföreningar, stora patientföreningar, stora folkrörelseorganisationer som gör medlems-tidningar, som har nyhetssajter, skickar nyhetsbrev, jag poddar och sånt.
Och då är det de gör i något annat det de är bra på.
Och då lägger man ut den här delen, så man skapar en professionell redaktion hos oss på A4.
Är inte det lite svårt som reporter eller journalist, att nu är ditt uppdrag att skriva om det här fackförbundet i fyra år?
Det kanske inte var det man trodde att man skulle jobba med.
Måste man inte ha ett intresse för det man skriver om?
Jo, vi är ju egentligen som vilken redaktion som helst.
Ska du vara på Aftonbladet i fem år, måste du ha ett intresse för den sortens journalistik.
Och sitter man med mig och jobbar med ledarskapsjournalistik, så måste man ha ett visst intresse av det.
Så att, så är det ju.
Jag tycker det är spännande, man tänkte att nu ska jag ut och göra, vad heter det, wall ruffa upp någon djup nyhet om någon här och sätta dit dem och så skriver jag.
Men det kanske är en klysa om journalister, är det inte det?
Jag har ingen aning, det funkar inte så länge.
Jag tänker att alla journalister lever i någon sorts idealisk värld där de vill sätta dit makthavare, det är det man går igång på.
Det kanske inte är så länge.
Jag tror att många drivs av att de vill berätta historier, vill förändra saker såklart, men kanske inte genom den slags journalistik som du beskriver den.
Kan vi inte stanna lite grann i det där med att på något sätt, nu pratar jag ju mer ur en kommersiell, du pratar ju lite mer om föreningar men de är också på ett sätt kommersiella, de måste ju dra in vittämmar och liknande.
Det är bara en annan enhet.
Ja, det här med att bygga community och man ska bygga någon sorts samhörighet, det är ju ett ultratrendord i våran bransch.
På e-handel ska ju alla bygga, jag vet inte, kundklubbar och liknande.
Men hur gör man för att skapa en bra produkt?
Det är jättemånga som har pratat med mig om det här med poddar, eller om hur man ska nå ut och hur man ska bygga den här samlingen.
Har du någon input där?
Uppenbarligen är detta en modell som ni jobbar i enligt, men vad funkar och vad funkar inte?
Hur nischad ska man vara och vad ska man tänka på?
Det har ju förändrats något enormt.
Det finns ju liksom inte en kanal längre som kan göra ditt jobb.
Du måste bygga en kanalmix, du måste finnas i massa olika kanaler för att nå fram.
Och jag tror verkligen att ju mer nischad, desto enklare är det att nå sin målgrupp.
För då kan du bli väldigt precis och göra precis det slags innehåll eller den journalistik som din målgrupp vill ha.
Ju bredare målgruppen har, desto svårare det är att pricka rätt att skriva om saker eller göra grejer som folk vill läsa om.
Om man tittar på de tidskrifter, kommersiella tidskrifter som har överlevt eller som fortfarande går bra, så är de ju ofta väldigt nischade.
Det är för dig som är superintresserad av att läsa om historia i andra värld.
Det finns ju så jättenischade tidskrifter som funkar.
Men de här bredare, mode, heminredning, oerhört svårt.
Det är så brett och det finns så mycket.
Finns det någon märklig paradox där i att jag bara tänker att hela det här AI-grejset där, det produceras ofantligt mycket material.
Jag läste någonstans för, kan det ha varit ett halvår sedan eller nånting, att just då publicerades mer än hälften av allting som publicerades på nätet var aviskrivet.
Så vi gick förbi den där tipping point.
Och nu är det väl ännu mer.
Men på något sätt så gör ju det att vi söker, när vi väl ska få in riktig fakta så blir ju sådana tidningar, om ni nu skriver om forskning då till exempel, så blir ju det en riktig källa om du förstår vad jag menar.
Samtidigt så kanske folk blir mindre benägna att betala för det.
För att det känns som att jag kan få information gratis sammanfattat, sen litar jag på den eller inte, jag vet inte men den är gratis.
Det är någon sorts märklig dubbel.
Men det är verkligen, det är ju dubbelt.
För de här AI-sammanfattningarna i söpmotorerna har ju minskat trafiken något enormt till tidningar och tidskrifter.
Samtidigt tänker jag att om man skriver om saker som inte egentligen kan sammanfattas på fem rader, då finns det ändå en framtid.
Det finns människor som vill förstå mer och läsa mer.
Och det finns ju frågor som faktiskt inte kan sammanfattas på fem rader.
Och jag tänker att det vi gör faller inom det.
Vi har inte märkt av jättestora tapp heller.
Märker du att folk fuskar, dina reporter eller journalister, kan du se att det här har inte du skrivit?
Kom igen nu.
Jag tycker att det är helt rimligt att man använder AI-verktyg som finns.
Det vore ju superkonstigt om man inte gjorde det.
Och jag tycker att man ser ju, idag börjar man ju verkligen kunna se när det har varit lite för mycket AI-verktyg inblandad.
Men jag kan tycka att det är en svår för att ibland skriver vissa så här tillskrifter om gymkompaniiet och då kan jag se att reporterna har använt AI-verktyg och sammanfattat infotexter om oss för de har blandat ihop.
Till exempel inlägg jag har skrivit på LinkedIn så skriver de så här, Joel var här och gjorde det här.
Och jag vet att det stämmer inte.
Jag var där och jag gjorde det där men det var på en annan plats.
Jag skrev det om ett annat men AI-verktyget har klumpat ihop det.
Och det är väldigt svårt att fact checka för att för journalisten så blir det väldigt rimligt att så här, ja men det här låter rimligt och de kanske känner igen grejerna så de tar det som en sanning, men det stämmer inte, det är ihopblandat.
Det tycker jag är en stor risk att fakta blir, det är fortfarande fakta men den är liksom krånglig fakta.
Alltså AI är ju otroligt bra för analys av enorma databaser och sånt där.
Där har AI öppnat dörrar för journalistiken som förr var helt omygliga, eftersom den kan gå igenom databaser med material som skulle ha krävt 20 pers i flera år.
Men just i att skriva artiklar, nej, det är ju oerhört svårt och blir det ju jättefel eftersom det är som du säger de hittar på.
Men som bollplank som, ja men du vet ett sätt att hantera också stora texter.
Om du istället för att lägga en hel dag på läsarna avhandling, så finns det ju verktyg idag som kan hjälpa dig att sammanfatta den och förstå den och sen kanske ringa upp forskaren och kunna ställa ganska smarta frågor.
Då kommer du ju rätt och då har du använt AI-verktygen som stöd.
Men det är inte de som skriver artiklarna.
Nej, jag bara tycker det är spännande.
Men det är klart att det finns säkert de som gör det.
Men det är som du säger, det brukar märkas.
Jag tror att en av anledningen till att jag har den här nostalgiska känslan, min farsa var journalist och vi hade gamla arkivskåp nere i källaren, sådana här stora lådor, så att om han skulle skriva en artikel om, jag vet inte, Olof Palme, då gick han dit och sökte han på P och så drog han ut och så låg det liksom tidningar där och då så hade han klippt ut alla urklipp om Palme då som han hade hittat under tolv år och sparat och kategoriserat.
Så att, så ser jag, och jag kan fatta att AI är lite mer effektivt i det fallet, men jag kan också tycka att det är lite syndigt, jag gillar det här gamla, det var lite vackert.
Men skitsamma, vi ska snacka lite ledarskap, för det är spännande och det är lite roligt.
Jag tänker, om vi snackar bara om ledarskap och sådant där, finns det liksom etablerade sanningar om vad gott ledarskap är, om vi knyter an lite till starten?
Finns det liksom, det här är goda ledare, det här är goda ledaregenskaper?
Ja, man sätter ju så här olika namn och olika etiketter på olika skolor eller vad man ska säga, men jag tycker väl ändå att det finns namn.
Ja men att det finns faktorer som hela tiden...
Vad menar du med olika skolor?
Ja men du vet, man kallar det för saker, man har ett tillitsbaserat ledarskap eller man har en anduet.
Det finns mycket namn på saker, men i grunden så är det väl faktorer som hela tiden återkommer.
Och vilka är de faktorerna?
Det som man kallar liksom ett svenskt eller ett nordiskt ledarskap, det är ju inte att peka med hela armen liksom, utan vi är ju vana vid ett mer demokratiskt ledarskap.
Och idag pratar man ju om, ja men du vet att om transparens.
Dina medarbetare behöver förstå dina beslut, för då kommer de bli mer engagerade och mer motiverade.
Du behöver liksom vara konsekvent, för att en ledare som man känner sig osäker på där, beslut kan gå åt ena hållet ena dagen och andra nästa.
Det blir oerhört tufft att jobba för en sån.
Du behöver ta ansvar, inte minst när någonting går fel, så behöver du vara den som ställer dig upp och säger att det här blev fel.
Man pratar ju jättemycket om psykologisk trygghet idag.
Att man behöver skapa organisationer, där dina medarbetare vågar räcka upp handen och säga någonting, när någonting är fel.
Därför att det kommer att hjälpa dig att fatta rätt beslut.
För att om inte du vet vad som händer uti organisationen så kommer du inte att märka någonting förrän det smäller i ansiktet på dig.
Fyssnatskultur är det samma sak.
Blir det tyst, är det ingen som vågar säga ifrån, är det ingen som vågar räcka upp handen när någonting går fel, då kommer det att bli problematiskt för dig som chef när det smäller.
För du sa det svenska ledarskapet eller nordiska ledarskapet, jag köper att det är en modell som vi uppskattar här då.
Men är det en modell som uppskattas på andra ställen eller vart går gränserna, har alla olika kulturer sin goda ledare?
Jag tror att det är skillnad.
Vi har pratat med många svenska chefer som har tagit toppjobb i andra länder och där det verkligen har blivit en krock i början.
För det som vi ser som att man bjuder in medarbetare att tycka till och vara med och att man lär en ansvariga lita på att du löser den här uppgiften, det blir såhär va otydligt om du är chef i ett annat land.
Jag pratade med en chef som hade jobbat i Japan, det blev som en blötfilt organisation.
Ingen visste vad de skulle göra, ingen pekade på dem och sa gör det här.
Här är det inte lika vanligt att man jobbar så.
Finns det en ledarkultur som rankar man ledarkultur på en världsnivå?
Vi tycker såklart att våran är bäst, men vi är en ganska liten del av världen.
Vi har inte störst produktion eller output i världen, utan är egentligen den kinesiska outputen bäst, eller den amerikanska eller den mexikanska?
Jag vill bara ifrågasätta om, har vi hittat rätt eller borde vi egentligen tänka om det?
Jag tror inte att det finns något v med ledarskapet.
Jag tror inte att någon rankar det så.
Men finns det vissa ledare som är eftertraktade i olika länder?
Kan man se att internationellt uppskattas ändå holländska ledare eller amerikanska ledare eller srilankanska ledare?
Finns det något sånt?
Nej?
Nej, jag tror inte att det gör det faktiskt.
För det är väl lite så att man funkar ju bra i sin egen kultur, såklart.
Så jag har inte sett det än visst.
Så när vi pratar ledarskap nu och gott ledarskap, då pratar vi ur en svensk eller nordisk kontext.
Ja, och jag tänker att man också kan prata ur något.
Det finns ju ett forskningsmännisko som är ledarskap, men i grund och botten är det ju ganska mycket organisationspsykologi och psykologi.
Det går ändå ut på någonstans att få människor att göra det du vill att de ska göra.
Att få dem att överträffa dig, att vara bättre än dig, att komma med nya idéer och ta ansvar.
Och i grund och botten är det ju liksom människor.
Att få människor att må bra och prestera.
Det är svårt att prestera, tänker jag, om man inte mår bra.
Någonstans finns det ju någon ganska mänsklig botten i det där.
Finns det någon, nu hamnar jag på väldigt nördiga frågor, det var inte meningen, men jag tycker det är kul.
Finns det någon gräns där människor mår för bra och slutar prestera?
Ja, ja.
Alltså, att må bra betyder ju inte i de här sammanhangen att man ska, det är så himla gött på jobbet.
Att jag går hit och har det mysigt med mina kollegor, det är ju inte grejen.
Det är ju superviktigt såklart att man använder sin energi till att göra det man ska göra.
Och det är väl det som är ledarskapet, att få människor att de timmarna av livet man är på och jobbet, då gör vi det här tillsammans och vi ansvänger oss för att det ska bli bra.
Jag upplever att ledarskapet har blivit det svenska då, har blivit mer inkluderande och mer transparent.
Allt det där som du sa under en ganska lång tid och det har blivit liksom snällare, alltså situationstecken snällare.
Men någonstans så kan jag uppleva att är vi lite i ett skifte där folk lite grann tröttnar på det snälla.
För att när jag lyssnar på vänner och liknande, när de pratar om sina arbetsplatser så kan jag uppleva att när de klagar på sina chefer så klagar de ofta nu mer på att chefen inte bara säger till det typ eller tar tag i det.
De saknar auktoritet på ett sätt eller de liksom var inte så jävla dalte i.
De kan nästan bli såhär, man kan sparka den, man kan inte göra så i Sverige.
Då får de väl skicka in dem i ett rum och sätta dem där.
Så upplever jag inte att folk pratade riktigt för tio år sen, utan jag tycker att vi rör oss mot en.
Men precis, men jag tror att det där verkligen, det tror jag är en av de vanligaste grejerna när man inte gillar sin chef.
Det är ju att man är otydlig, liksom.
Och är man otydlig, då kommer, det där kommer ju liksom då som en effekt av det, att folk blir såhär, men vafan.
Varför, varför är ingen som, säg ifrån, liksom.
Och att man upplever såhär att det blir orättvist.
Den där människan gör ju ingenting, och här sitter jag och sliter, liksom.
Allt det där bottnar ju i någon slags otydlighet och någon slags såhär, att man inte vågar ta de där obekräma samtalen.
Att man inte vågar säga ifrån när det är enskilda medarbetare som inte lever upp till eller tar reda på vad det är, liksom.
Vad är det som gör att det här inte funkar just nu, liksom.
Medarbetare märker ju såhär direkt, liksom.
Och det är ju superirriterande.
Är det så enkelt ledarskap egentligen att försöka vara transparent, ta konflikter när du ska ta dem, eller alltså, om man ska bli, det finns ju ex-antar människor som liksom vill bli chefer.
Alltså, det ligger i deras agenda att klättra och bli chefer.
Vad är det man ska lära sig?
Hur är det man ska tänka för att bli en god chef, eller?
Ja, alltså, ibland tänker jag att det är ju precis som du säger, det är inte svårare än att du ska vara bra på att liksom få människor att vilja jobba för dig.
Du ska vara tydlig så de förstår vad de ska göra.
Alltså, någonstans det handlar ju om människor, liksom.
Hur tänker du, liksom?
Hur definierar du ditt ledarskap?
Alltså, ganska mycket är det ju när jag har varit en riktigt dålig chef så är det ju när jag inte har tagit i konflikter tillräckligt fort oftast.
Jag kanske har tänkt på det i huvudet och så här hur fan ska jag hantera detta?
Eller hur ska jag göra detta?
Men det i sin tur drar ju ut på tiden.
Och så tillkommer det nya saker och då blir man lite så här ja okej, nu måste jag tänka om här.
Och det där går ju folk att undra på fan varför gör han ingenting?
Eller vad håller han på med?
Jäkar sig här, fixar det här nu bara.
Så att det är ju nästan alltid det att man inte är tillräckligt tydlig eller tillräckligt konkret och det är väl någonting man lär sig med tiden att långsamt, långsamt bli lite mer...
Ja men verkligen.
Konkret och tydlig, där man ska vara konkret och tydlig och att man ska försöka backa sina kollegor så långt det går.
Men det kan inte vara det som avgör om man är en god ledare eller inte.
Det måste ju finnas fler egenskaper som man ska...
Varför läser folk ledarskap?
Det finns ju 87 jävla böcker om ledarskap.
Det kan inte bara vara sida 1, vara tydlig och sen är det slut.
Vad fan står det i de här böckerna?
Ja, man kan säga mycket om det.
Jag tänker att det mycket hänger ihop för det är ju precis som du säger.
Om man tänker tillbaka på tillfällen man har haft när man själv kände att där var jag inte världens bästa chef.
Eller när man har haft chefer själv som man tyckte var idioter.
Så är det ju liksom konflikträdslor, att man inte vågar ta tag i konflikter.
Och vi vet ju hur det är med konflikter i grupper, att det sprider sig och det kan växa och bli helt ohanterligt.
Så att liksom, mycket av det här sakerna som är grunden till ett gott ledarskap, är ju egentligen någon slags grund i att vara en bra människa.
En bra medmänniska.
Men det som är speciellt när man är en chef är ju att man har en organisation, man har en grupp av människor framför sig, som man ska få att göra det du vill att de ska göra.
Men du ska också få dem att funka tillsammans, att lyfta varandra istället för att trycka ner varandra.
Det är ju komplext, det är ju inte lätt.
Och jag tänker att du kan ju läsa hur många böcker du vill om ledarskap.
Och det behöver du inte göra det lättare för att det ändå...
Jag tror stenhårt på någon slags learning by doing, att man måste jobba med sin grupp och se vad som funkar.
Men då krävs det ändå någon slags transparens och någon slags autenticitet, att du kan gå in där som dig själv och jobba med gruppen.
Har du några sådana lärdomar genom åren som du känner, fan det här var jag kast på i början, men nu har jag blivit hygglig på detta i alla fall.
Ja, men om jag tänker på mina första åren som redaktionell chef, tänkte jag inte tanke på ledarskap.
Det var inte så att man gick upp på morgonen och tänkte att, hur ska jag leda den här gruppen idag?
Jag och många med mig tror att man har ett driv i projektet man håller på med.
Du bygger bolag, ni håller på med era grejer.
Jag var så här, vi ska bli världens bästa redaktion, vi ska vinna priser, vi ska citeras gärna i media, vi ska ha hur mycket trafik som helst.
Och drivet i sakfrågan är det som driver en framåt.
Och om jag tittar tillbaka på den tiden så kan jag tänka att någon grej gjorde jag väl ändå rätt i det.
Att jag väldigt tidigt såg att mitt jobb var kratta manersen så att de här stjärnorna till reporter jag hade runt mig, att de kunde göra sitt jobb.
Jag gav dem förutsättningar att bli så bra som jag ville att de skulle bli.
Men jag var ju också drev på, alldeles för hårt ibland, gick jag fort fram, tittade mig aldrig över axeln och såg att alla andra var 200 meter bakom mig.
Jag är också en ganska lite otålig person.
Jag är inte personen som förvaltar, har lätt för att bara springa vidare.
Men jag tänker att det där är också en bra grej, och man vill bli en bra chef, att man lite reflekterar över sitt eget beteende och vågar både inför sig själv och andra säga att det där var inte så himla bra som jag gjorde häromdagen.
Det kan jag be om ursäkt för och nu ska vi göra såhär istället.
Det där säger ju alltid folk, att en bra chef vågar ta ansvar för sina problem, eller man vågar be om ursäkt, och vart går gränsen till att man bara blir ett, fan, slutar göra fel hela jävla tiden och bara, kunde någon.
Måste man be om ursäkt varje dag, kanske man ska fundera på.
Jag kan tycka att om vi tar, jag vet inte om du är bekväm med det så jag kan ta dialogen, och så får folk acceptera att nu pratar vi någon sorts filosofisk här, så skit i vilka personer vi pratar om, utan bara, såg du den här Rickard Lyko-ursäkten, för att de fick skära ner på personal.
Jag såg inte den, men jag såg alla reaktionerna runt den.
Men om man tar en sådan situation då, han gick ut och så bad han om ursäkt för att de fick skära ner på personal, och så blev han väldigt ledsen i sin film och så där, och han grät lite grann.
Även om folk säger att han grät, han fällde liksom en tår, det var inte så att han satt och stod och lipa i två minuter, utan han visade att han blev ledsen.
Är det liksom att ta ansvar för, skulle du säga att det är positivt, att det stärker ledarbilden, eller blir det bara att folk på golvet känner, ja du blir lite ledsen med det jag som förlorar jobbet.
När blir chefen bara en, att man inte fattar medarbetarnas riktiga problem, de skiter väl ifall du är ledsen, de tappar ju sin lön.
Jag bara menar, när blir det lite att man tror att man är down with the guys.
Och nu, jag pratar inte heller om personen här men.
Vi skiter i det här men jag bara tar det som ett exempel.
Saker man gör i sociala medier eller utåt, eller i vanliga medier, det är ju marknadsföring, skulle jag säga.
Det är inte det som påverkar gruppen eller så.
Men om man har en stor grupp där man måste varsla en massa folk, jag har ändå intervjuat ganska många chefer genom åren som har gjort det, som har gjort stora varsel och det har inte varit kul.
Och det de flesta säger är ju att om man ändå är rak och transparent och förklarar varför, vi måste göra så här därför att, då blir det liksom enklare för alla parter.
Men sen har man ju såklart, det är klart man blir ledsen om man förlorar sitt jobb.
Det är ju helt självklart liksom.
Men det rimliga man kan göra som chefer är väl att vara transparent.
Det här, vi gjorde en satsning, det gick inte som vi ville.
Vi är ledsna men liksom, så här måste det bli nu.
Det finns inga alternativ.
Jag tänker det har väl verkligen många chefer i Sverige som de senaste åren har tvingat sig upp en väldig massa folk.
Finns det någon forskning som du känner till på att chefers känslor spelar någon sorts roll i svåra situationer?
Eller är det bara det Outcom som spelar roll?
Hur menar du det?
Alltså ifall jag säger till mina kollegor att jag är ledsen, ni får ingen löneförhöjning nästa år.
Jag är jätteledsen för det, jag verkligen är ledsen för det.
Eller om jag, alltså bryr dem sig ifall jag är ledsen.
Alltså spelar det egentligen någon roll om folk har åsikter om resultatet blir dåligt.
Ja, nej.
Jag tror att de kanske inte bryr sig om det blir ledsen, men det är ändå lättare.
Man vill inte känna sig lurad.
Man vill inte känna, om man förlorar jobbet, tvingas gå ner i tid, får en lönerevision man inte är nöjd med, så behöver man åtminstone förstå varför.
Om man som chef luktar förklarar varför det ser ut så här, så tror jag att de flesta tuggar i sig det liksom.
Men att känna att jag blir lurad här, för det är någon annan som vinner på min bekostnad, då blir man väl inte lika glad tänkte jag.
Du pratade förut om det här med toxiska beteenden, den här studien som ni pratade om.
Vad är de stora toxiska beteendena som chefer gör?
Finns det några såhär, och kanske framförallt finns det toxiska beteenden som vi som inte, jag är ju inte psykopat.
Jag tror faktiskt att väldigt stora chefer är det.
Men ändå har ju jag negativa beteenden.
Finns det några negativa beteenden som folk gör som ändå försöker vara goda eller goda chefer, men som de bara fan, det här måste du bara ändra, du måste bara bli bättre på detta.
Finns det några sådana, sen fattar jag att det är toxiskt om man mobbar sin personal.
Jag fattar det.
Men liksom, vanliga människor, vad är de stora toxiska beteendena som man behöver tänka på?
Ja.
Nu sitter hela gymkompaniiet och bara väntar på att du ska säga det där som jag gör fel så att jag slutar med det.
Men jag tror att det är precis som du säger att chefer är ju...
Jag tror att det är ytterst få psykopater i chefsleden.
Man är en dålig chef ibland för att man inte har rätt förutsättningar eller för att det sitter något i väggarna för att man inte tänker efter.
Och man ägnar sig åt härska tekniker och grejer utan att man riktigt tänker på det.
Jag tänker att mikrostyrningen, att man lägger sig i saker som man inte ska lägga sig i så att man kan uppleva att man inte litar på folk.
Det tror jag är ett ganska vanligt fel som chefer gör.
Det kan vara att man har någon slags kontrollbehov.
Men det där måste man, för det att ha någon som hänger över ens axel, det är ju inte så kul.
Så att favorisera medarbetare tror jag också kan vara otroligt giftigt.
Och det är inte heller så här.
Jag tror inte att man är riktigt medveten om vad det kan ställa till om man alltid går och käkar lunch med någon, men inte frågar någon annan.
Eller om man, när man ska åka på konferens, säger man du kan samåka med mig, men de andra fick, alltså du vet, man tänker inte att det är dåligt, men det kan bli jävligt dåligt liksom.
Och så tror jag också att så här, konflikträdsla och otydlighet, det kan ju verkligen gå snett och upplevas som om att man är en väldigt dålig chef liksom.
Jag gillar det.
Mikrostyrning, favorisering och konflikträdsla.
Det är tre enkla, det tycker jag folk.
Tre bra grejer att jobba på.
Och det är liksom, alltså de flesta människor tycker att konflikter är jobbiga liksom.
Annars är man ju nästan psykopat och man tycker att det är kul med konflikter.
Så det är ju en jobbig grej liksom.
Men det kan man ju, man kan ju faktiskt träna på det.
Eller jag tror att man måste träna på det.
Träna på, som du säger, att när man märker att någonting är på gång, att man inte väntar, att man tar det direkt och så där.
Jag tänker att man kommer märka då att det kanske inte är så tufft som man tror.
Finns det något bra sätt att få feedback som ledare?
Upplever du att bra ledare, de ofta själv introspekter, sitter och tänker på sitt ledarskap eller kör de bara på?
Eller har de fått bra människor utomifrån som har sagt åt dem att fan, fixa det här nu?
Du behöver ta hand om de här dragar.
Vad är det som får folk att utvecklas i rätt riktning?
Vad är det man behöver fokusera på?
Du menar att om man som chef vill utvecklas som chef.
Ja, precis.
Jag tänker att man måste väl, ibland kan det väl vara att man faktiskt har fått en signal utifrån.
Kanske från en högre chef som säger att det här måste du tänka på.
För jag tror ju att många chefer gör dumma grejer utan att tänka på det.
Och då är det ju viktigt att man ändå har någon slags kultur där man kan säga det, utan att man blir superkränkt eller upplever det som en jätteskarp kritik när det kanske i själva verket bara är en feedback för att hjälpa en.
Det är supersvårt med feedback.
Men jag brukar tänka, vi har sagt det några gånger, att chefer där aldrig medarbetarna har sagt nåt negativt.
De har aldrig sagt att det där var inte så bra eller det där var inte så bra.
Då kanske man ändå ska tänka att vad har vi för kultur?
Kan man räcka upp handen och säga?
I den bästa av världen kan man ju avdramatisera det.
Att man hittar ett sätt att prata med varandra, där det faktiskt är okej att säga det blev ju dålig stämning på mötet igår.
Att någon kan säga det till dig.
Utan att du tar det som en stor grej, utan att den som säger det känner att han riskerar nånting.
Då blir det ju bara ett sätt där man som grupp försöker bli bättre, ha roligare på jobbet, göra kul grej ihop.
Men det där är ju supersvårt skulle jag vilja säga.
De som är duktiga på det får ju också effektiva organisationer runt sig.
Tycker du att chefer generellt sett är lite fjantiga?
De kan ha svårt att ta kritik, men det är många som säger att det är så ensamt på toppen, att jag måste bära på allt ansvar.
Man kan ju sluta om man vill, det är inte någon som tvingar.
Hur ska man lära sig att hantera allt det där utan att bli ömplig?
Ja, men ömplig tror jag är ingen bra strategi.
Det tror jag inte man ska satsa på.
Jag ber om ursäkt till alla som har riktiga problem.
Jag fattar att det kan vara skitjobbigt, men ibland blir det så här fan, det var så tufft under de där åren.
Det var rätt tufft för dem som fick sparken också.
Det var inte skitkul för dem.
Nej, jag tänker så här att de allra flesta chefer i Sverige, det är ju mellanchefer, väldigt många av dem i offentlig sektor.
Ganska tuffa jobb där man har hårt tryck från alla håll.
Man har hårt tryck underifrån, men man har också ett hårt tryck uppifrån.
Från ledning eller från politisk ledning, och man har otillräckliga resurser, man sliter med personalärenden där man känner att man går lite emot sin egen.
Man fattar vad det här handlar om.
Den här människan håller på att gå sönder.
Men jag måste ändå pressa den här människan att göra det här.
Jag tror att de faktiskt sitter på många chefer och har ganska tuffa situationer.
Och det är klart att man alltid kan, ja du kan väl byta jobb.
Jag fattar, jag generaliserar, extremt kul.
Jag menar ju de här som får 1,3 miljoner i månaden.
Och så måste de säga upp 20 personer och så tycker de att det var en tuff omställning.
Man bara ja okej, men sen fattar jag att...
Jag tänker att de flesta chefer har ju inte så jätteglamburrösa valet faktiskt.
Jag fattar det.
Någon på socialkontoret som måste häva någons bidrag.
Jag fattar att det inte är svinkul liksom.
Nej.
Jag förstår, så märklig jag inte som människa.
En annan fråga som jag skulle vilja lyfta är, det kommer ju upp sådana här, det kommer ju även på Facebook, alla sådana här, så här funkar generation, xyz, det där dö, så här, det här är vad de här drivs av, det här drivs baby boomers av, man ska, du vet sånt där.
Är det så tydligt i ledarskap att ska man anpassa sitt, behöver man anpassa sitt ledarskap efter generationer och kanske efter kön och efter, är det en grej eller är man som man är?
Ja precis, det är väl en grej i den bemärksen att det är många som pratar om det.
Om man tittar på forskning, då finns det nog, det finns liksom, vad är generation och vad är ålder?
Det finns ju en grej att man såklart ser annorlunda på livet om man är 20 eller om man är 50, den äldre generationen har vi alltid tyckt att den yngre generationen är lite illojal och hopplös att ha att göra med.
Sen är det ju onekligen så att de senaste 30 åren, 20 åren har det ju hänt så sjukt mycket i världen, i livet.
Så det vore ju väldigt konstigt om den generation som kommer ut på arbetsmarknaden nu skulle vara likadant som den som kom ut när vi kom ut.
Så att de är annorlunda beror väl på att världen är annorlunda, samtiden är annorlunda.
Jag kan tycka att vissa grejer som man anklagar generation Z för, att de är lojala och inte sitter över och gör övertid, att de byter arbetsgivare hela tiden och så, det är ju, kan jag tänka, inte helt dåliga egenskaper.
Ganska sunt, det är väl bara att byta jobb om man inte trivs på jobbet.
Men jag tänker att de ställer krav på chefer på ett annat sätt.
För att förr kanske man jobbade kvar till guldklockan, och chefer kom och chefer gick, och var de dåligaste pratade man om det i kafferummet, och så var det bra med det.
Det kanske inte den unga generationen gör på samma sätt, utan de biter jobb, eller kanske de också är mycket modigare att de ställer frågor och ställer chefer till svars.
Man pratar ju om att de behöver bekräftelse, och de behöver så mycket bekräftelse.
Men det kan ju också vara att de behöver någon slags feedback på vad de gör.
Vad gör jag?
Gör jag rätt?
Gör jag fel?
Jag vill bli bättre på det här, berätta vad jag kan göra.
Att de liksom, jag tror att de ställer hårdare krav på sina chefer.
Det tyder det att man då som chef på något sätt är ute efter det här, är det chefernas ansvar att anpassa sig, eller är det mer, ah, ni får anpassas in i hur arbetslivet funkar, så här funkar det här.
Vilka är det som ska anpassa sig?
Är det rätt att, har de rätt eller har de fel?
Men jag tänker att det är ju svårt att sitta kvar i en arbetsplatskultur som formades för 40 år sedan och säga till människor som kommer in att här jobbar vi såhär, världen förändras och effekten kommer väl bara att bli att unga människor lämnar organisationen i så fall.
Vi vill inte jobba här, det här verkar inte kul.
Så att det är lite svårt att säga, här jobbar vi såhär.
Eller det kan man ju säga, men då får man liksom, då får man effekten.
Då får man inga anställda.
Fan okej, då måste vi anpassa oss.
Jag pratar som att jag tillhör den äldre i hela nationen, det gör jag väl inte riktigt men.
Tycker du att det är någon skillnad då?
Ja det är en skillnad absolut.
Vad är skillnaden då?
De unga, nu har ju inte jag så jävla många anställda, vi är ett litet föredrag, vi är nio pers, jag hårdrar ju det här så att stackars Pontus, när han lyssnar på detta, han vet ju att jag pratar om honom för han är inst liksom.
Men de kommer ju med en lite mer vald verklighet på något sätt.
Jag kan uppleva att de kanske lite mer upplever att ja men så här är världen och jag vill att världen ska vara så här.
Medans de som är lite äldre, de är lite mer, okej, livet är lite som livet är och så får man anpassa sig och så är det skit den dagen, då är det skit den dagen.
Det är liksom ingen som har bestämt att det är skit den dagen.
Men det får man tugga i sig och så går man vidare och nästa dag hoppas man att det är lite mindre skit.
Det är lite den jag upplever, när man pratar om filterbubblor och sånt i sociala medier så kan jag liksom se att det också har format hur yngre personer kanske kan tro lite mer att deras verklighet är en större del av verkligheten än vad den faktiskt är.
Det är antagligen bara du som tycker så, vi andra tycker inte så.
Bara för att du ser 2 000 andra människor som tycker så, så det betyder ingenting för de kan vara utspridda över hela världen.
I det här fikarummet så tycker alla såhär.
Det tycker jag är den största skillnaden att unga människor kanske tenderar att dras lite mer mot att tro att världen är lite mer så som de tror att världen är.
Medan äldre liksom mer inställda på att de är bara ett pyttelitet kugghjul i en jättestor mekanism.
Man har inte lika stor påverkan på världen liksom.
Nej, men jag tänker de har växt upp i en större värld.
Det är som du säger, de har levt i en digital värld där de kan ha vänner över hela världen.
Och sen är de, precis som äldre personer också, så är man ju i någon slags bubbla där det finns en sanning liksom.
Men jag tänker att det kan ju vara precis det som ställer krav på chefer på ett annat sätt.
Att man behöver vara tydlig liksom.
Här jobbar vi såhär.
Och här är det det här som gäller.
Förr kanske det var enklare att man förstod det när man kom in.
Eller bara tuggade man i sig och lärde sig med tiden.
Jag vet inte.
Men jag tänker att de också kommer med, Gen KZ kommer ju med andra kompetenser och andra insikter.
Det finns ju otroligt mycket att hämta.
Jaja såklart.
Jag pratar ingenting om kompetens i detta, eller hur man fungerar som arbetstagare.
Vi, Jakob som vi har som lagchef är väldigt yngst på lagret tror jag.
Det har ju liksom inte med det att göra skulle jag inte säga.
Har du fem minuter då att snacka lite andra klishor och liknande?
För då går vi in i det.
Alla ni som hatar att lyssna på alla, är det skillnad på kön och är det skillnad på ålder och sånt där, ni kan ju liksom stänga av nu, ni kan torna ut.
För nu går jag in på några klishor, men jag tycker ändå det är intressant att fråga.
Jag kan uppleva att för tio år sedan såg jag ut som en liten kallisk kaviar pojke, väldigt ljust hår och betydligt längre hår och inte alls lika många rynker som jag har idag.
Så då behövde jag ju på något sätt, jag inbillade mig att jag behövde få mer aktöritet genom mitt sätt att agera, eller vad man ska säga.
Medan nu så har jag varit med lite längre och jag ser konstant arg ut och rynkegyt.
Så det är som att folk ger det mer respekt.
Finns de effekterna på riktigt?
Är det så, ibland läser man ju att långa människor får bättre jobb eller högre lön.
Är det liksom sådär att ett visst utseende lämpar sig och en viss, säga man kontra kvinna eller äldre kontra ung, finns det liksom forskning på vad man lyssnar på?
Det finns ju inte forskning så vad man lyssnar på.
Men jag tänker såhär, det finns ju massa forskning som visar att det är lättare att få jobb om du ser bra ut, det är svårare att få jobb om du är överviktig.
Jaha är det en grej också?
Ja men det har med utseende och appearance liksom, det finns massor av sådant.
Åldersdiskriminering pratar man ju mycket om idag, att liksom redan efter 40 års ålder så kallas man inte längre till intervjuer liksom, i vissa branscher skulle man ju säga.
Är det även åt andra ålder?
Kallas man inte på intervjuer upp till 25?
Finns det någon åldersdiskriminering åt yngre?
Eller är det alltid riktat åt äldre?
Jag tänker såhär, man vill ju inte heller ha, alltså de som inte har något CV än eller som är för unga, de tror jag också har det supersvårt på arbetsmarknaden just nu.
Det känns som att det är den där mellan typ 28 och 38 då ska man vara.
Är det inte de man borde hata för det är de man har som har barn?
Det är absolut värsta tiden när man vabbade jämnt.
Hemskt.
Ja, det är också helt knäppt att det är så.
Sådant forskning finns det, det finns ju massa forskning runt jämställdhet mellan könen.
Det är inte i hur man utför sitt ledarskap, utan det är väl snarare att få chansen att utföra ledarskapet.
Det är ju fortfarande så att ni bland toppchefer och styrelser i börsnoterade företag och så, så är det ont om kvinnor, det är för att de inte får chansen.
Är det samma sak i, för nu säger det ju styrelser och börsnoterade företag, det är en värld som på något sätt är väldigt elitistisk.
Är det samma sak i om vi skulle säga företag som har 100-500 anställda?
Gör man forskning på sådana bolag och kollar?
Jo men det gör man ju.
Där ser man den här epikten med kön också.
Däremot är det så att i offentlig sektor, där jobbar det väldigt mycket kvinnor.
Och de senaste tio åren har det verkligen skett en förändring där.
Där är väl nästan majoriteten av skötna kvinnor idag.
Då är det också lägre löner och lägre prestige där.
Som ofta är där kvinnor är.
Det finns ju till exempel forskning på något som heter dottereffekten.
Och jag tänker att den visar väldigt tydligt att vi är i grunderbottan, är vi människor och vi påverkas av våra egna liv.
Den visar att män, manliga vd-ar som får en dotter, börjar helt plötsligt intressera sig för jämställdhetsfrågor och börjar se att jag kanske behöver kvinnliga chefer i min ledningsgrupp.
Och då ökar andelen kvinnor dramatiskt.
Och nu finns det också såhär på styresordföranden.
När styresordföranden får en dotter, då ökar andelen kvinnor i styrelsen.
Jag kan verkligen se att det stämmer.
Bara från liksom, vad säger man, kvalitativ under...
Alltså bara från historier.
Det är så jävla tydligt, folk som har varit, du vet, grabb grabbar och sen så får de en dotter.
Och så helt plötsligt går de in i föreningslivet och tjejerna ska ha bättre träningstid.
Alltså såhär, jag kan verkligen se att det stämmer.
Ja men det är så, man är liksom närmast sig själv på något sätt.
Så det visar ju ändå att det är ganska simpla krafter som styr, du vet vilka är det som styr våra företag, vilka är det som är chefer i våra stora offentliga organisationer och sen i grund och botten är det otroligt basala krafter som man behöver jobba emot.
Nu, jag kan tycka dottereffekten kan leva med ett bra sätt att försöka få jämställdhet.
Men att vi är biased liksom som i Sverige är det oerhört svårt att få jobb med arabiskt klingande efternamn till exempel.
Det finns ju massa forskning gjord på att då blir man inte kallad överhuvudtaget så finns det ju liksom en rasism på arbetsmarknaden som man verkligen kan forska kring därför att man ser vilka som blir kallade.
Funkar det på samma sätt där att det handlar mer om att få jobbet än att bli befodrad?
Eller handlar det om hela hela skalan eller vad man ska säga?
Ja det är hela skalan, det finns forskning både på rekrytering men också karriär inom organisationer och så.
Ja det är spännande.
Kan man se att, jag har två pojkar senare då, blir jag mer sexistisk då i mitt ledarskap?
Du ringer lite illa till det här va?
Jag bara tänker om man blir mer bedrövlig åt andra hållet.
Om det är en grej är det kanske att man inte ger någon forskning på mig.
Nej jag har inte sett någon sån forskning.
Men det är inte så konstigt man blir formad av sina erfarenheter.
Har du en dotter kanske som får erfarenheter som visar att det är sämre träningstider, som du säger, för tjejlagen.
Men då helt plötsligt ser du saker som du aldrig har sett för liksom.
Jag tänker framförallt att man inte tar fighten för det.
Nu vet jag att mina pojkar är så småsidda och de har liksom inte börjat fotboll än.
Men jag tänker, hockey och konståkning var ju en grej för.
Jag spelade inte hockey men jag hörde, för jag hade en tjejkompis som åkte konståkning.
Och då fick jag alltid de skitdåliga tider, trots att de vann VM och liknande.
Och jag tänker att har man pojkar så kanske, som går i hockey då, vi bara generaliserar grovt här.
Fan alla ni som bara tycker att jag generaliserar, lo, det är så, ni får bara, det är för att vi ska få en dialog.
Men då tänker jag att då tar man, man kanske ser att, ja det är orättvist men man tar inte fighten, för det hade ju försämrat det för ens egna ungar som går i den.
Så jag är på något sätt, som du säger, man är sig själv närmast.
En annan sak, jag fan förlåt att jag drar över, jag har varit så färggull.
Jag äger ju gymkompaniet själv, och det finns ju någon sorts så här, vacker tanke kring familjeföretag, du vet det går i arv, och så ska ens barn ta över och de ska ta över.
Men det är ju egentligen stenhård nepotism.
Att så här, ja, här finns folk som har jobbat i företaget i 20 år, men det är min unge som ska bli vd för den här, du vet.
Finns det forskning på om det är bra att ens barn tar över eller inte?
Går liksom familjeföretag, blir de bra chefer eller blir de också såna här bedrövliga människor som spelar bort alla sina pengar och bete sig dåligt mot personalen för att de inte har fått kämpa?
Är liksom andra generationens chefer sämre än första generationens?
Alltså jag vet.
Kronlig fråga kanske.
Nej, det borde finnas forskning på det.
Men jag kan inte minnas att jag har sett den.
Däremot så såg jag nyligen att det finns siffror på att det finns massor av familjeägda företag i landet där det inte finns ingen tronföljare.
Barnen tar inte över.
Eller det finns inga anställda heller som tar över.
Och när man slår ihop det så, nu kommer jag inte ihåg siffran, men det var en väldigt hög siffra på hur mycket arbetstillfällen det är.
Så det där är verkligen en fråga att fundera på.
Sverige är ju framförallt en väldig massa företag som är mindre.
Men som tillsammans är en stor del av arbetskraften.
Så det är ju superviktigt att det finns någon slags livskraft i dem som inte bara är kopplade till grundaren eller ägaren.
Varför ska barnen ta över eller det finns inget incitament?
Verkligen bara om de vill, tänker jag.
Och jag hoppas att det är så att när barn tar över så har man kanske växt upp i företaget och jobbat i företaget och vill ta över.
Det ser man ju fortfarande.
Men jag tror också att man ser ganska mycket företag när det inte barnen vill ta över.
Jag försöker få in mina.
Vi åkte förbi Trollhättan igår där vi ska byta, vi ska flytta lager dit, så då tog jag med min fyraåring och femårighin där vi håller på att renovera där nu.
Och så försökte jag få dem att förstå.
Titta, titta vilket fint lager, pojken.
Det här ska ni värdera, det här är viktigare än iPad liksom.
Kolla nu, de bara ja, ett stort rum.
De tyckte mest då kul att eka liksom.
Nej, slutade.
Helene, stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Jättekul att få prata.
Varför läser folk ledarskap?
Det finns ju 87 jävla böcker om ledarskap.
Det kan inte bara vara sida 1, vara tydlig och sen är det slut.
Vad fan står det i de här böckerna?